-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
This is my first time ever
on late-night television.
-Really? Well, we're
very honored to have you.
-Thank you so much.
-I am such a huge fan
of this show.
I'm such a huge fan
of you on the show.
For anybody
who hasn't caught up,
this is a prequel
to "Breaking Bad."
Had you -- Were you a fan
of "Breaking Bad" before this?
-I had never seen "Breakin
Bad,"
but I remember,
I was at my father's place
and they were watching
the finale of "Breaking Bad.
I walked in on the finale.
-That's what they say -- Jump in
on the last episode, yeah.
-Come in only when it gets good.
But I remember
seeing that episode
and thinking it was
breathtaking.
I saw the name Vince Gilligan,
and I made a mental note
to myself.
And three weeks later,
I had an audition,
and lo and behold, the nam
Vince Gilligan was on it.
And if you ever believe in fate,
that felt like a moment of fat
right there.
-That's fantastic.
This show, I will admit,
and I've said this
to other people on the show,
when I first heard the ide
that there was going to be
this prequel,
it sounded like a bad idea
to me,
and yet it is so good
and so riveting.
And you play, I feel like,
a character
that we've seen this path before
in the "Breaking Bad" universe
of, you have made
a few bad decisions,
and they just
continue to domino,
and things continue
to get worse.
-And you try to be good,
and a lot --
You do a lot of face actin
of just realizing
how much [bleep] you're in
-Yeah, there's --
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
A lot of the character --
A lot of the acting
is non-dialogue based.
-And the character's definitel
walking a razor blade,
and it's just a hell
of a roller coaster ride, man.
We're having a blast.
-It is very stressful to watch
I imagine the scenes
like the clip we saw,
they must be stressful to do
Do you have a way to decompres
after shooting?
-A lot of chocolate.
A lot of ice cream.
A lot of crying
in the shower at night.
[ Laughter ]
But I'd like to do --
I've taken on Muay Thai.
-Okay, Muay Thai.
-Mixed martial arts.
I really enjoy doing that
and hot yoga.
-Hot yoga?
-Yeah.
-You did martial arts
from a young age.
-Oh, very seriously, yes.
-This is a photo you poste
recently on Instagram. And
there you are back in the day.
-There you go, yeah.
-No, you do not want
to run into that kid
in the lunch room, yeah.
He is going home with your milk.
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly what I was
thinking in that photo.
I don't know
who took that photo,
but I can tell
that I thought I looked badass
-Yeah.
-But the person taking it
must have thought
that I didn't look like --
-It's really funny.
I got young kids now.
It's the funniest thing
when they try to look cool
for a picture.
And, like, everyone's laughing
and they're like,
"I'm a cool dude."
-"I'm a bad --
-You had a sort of
wild upbringing.
You grew up all over the place
You were born in Quebec, yes
-Yes.
-You lived in Africa.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you sort of missed
American pop culture for a time.
-Completely. You know, the onl
thing -- We didn't have any TV
and the only music I knew
was Michael Jackson.
-Yep, worldwide.
-And Prince, yeah.
And anything that kind of was,
like, super box office
from America would trickle over.
So there was like Sylveste
Stallone, Eddie Murphy,
and that was it.
I only know three actors.
[ Laughter ]
And I learned to speak English
watching these movies.
-That's fantastic.
-A lot of F-bombs
watching Eddie Murphy.
-Yeah. You just spoke
in Arnold Schwarzenegger-isms.
-Right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is an American accent
-"The first thing I learne
how to say was, 'I'll be back.'"
-There you go.
-You shoot the show
in New Mexico.
-Mm-hmm.
-Just like "Breaking Bad."
I have spent some time
in New Mexico.
My wife's family is from there
-Your -- Yeah.
-Yeah, and a lot of snakes
-Yes.
-This is an issue for you.
You are not a fan of snakes.
-Very -- No, not at all.
Very serious issue.
I'm terrified of snakes.
And I was really, really scared.
Every time I'd look
at the script,
the first thing is, am I dead?
And then the second thing is
do we have to shoot outdoors
where there are snakes?
Those were my two biggest fears,
to the point
that Jennifer Bryan,
the costume designer, and
thought it'd be, you know --
'cause I'm a huge music fan.
-Yeah.
-And I love Quincy Jones.
And Quincy Jones,
I saw an interview of him,
and he said, you take the thre
worst songs on an album,
and you make them
your three best.
So I thought, why don't I
take the worst thing
about this shooting,
which are snakes,
and incorporate it?
And we have Nacho now --
-Yeah, he's a big snake fan.
You can see.
I don't know if we can get him
but you're always wearing
a snake earring.
You're very snake-based.
-Yes.
Jennifer Bryan,
the costume designer, and
thought it'd be a good ide
to embrace that.
-There you go.
Embrace the snake.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
One of the things, it's hard
for me to talk to you abou
because you only saw the las
episode of "Breaking Bad" --
Your character --
-No, I saw the whole thing
-You did see the whole thing
-Yeah, for research,
and I loved it. I loved it
-You would have known this
but obviously, your characte
is not in "Breaking Bad,"
and a lot of people die
in this show.
So, do you know yet?
Have they told you your fate
-They haven't told me yet,
but I have to be honest.
I think about it like this
I think, you know,
the character, it's -- For me,
it's a story of redemption
It's a character
who did bad choices
and is trying
to do the right thing,
trying to save his father
and get out of the cartel.
So, whatever happens, you know
whether he dies or not,
I hope just,
at least metaphysically
he gets a second chance.
-Well, it's been a fantastic
journey to watch.
You're so great
as the character.
And thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you. Thank you very much.
-So honored
that this was your first.
Michael Mando!
[ Cheers and applause ]